Bladesmiths, in your first
round of competition today,
you'll be using these.
[dramatic music playing]
On this table,
we've got ball bearings,
bandsaw blades,
bike chain,
we've got all manner
of high-carbon steel.
And in this first round
of competition,
you'll have to choose at least
three of the steels here
and combine them
with 1095 powder
into a canoe canister
to make
a canister Damascus billet
from which you will forge
a signature blade
in your signature style.
Good luck.
Your time starts now.
[dramatic rock music playing]
We've got the Hardmans
versus the Harrisons over here.
Competing against each other
and then against each other
at the same time.
The potential biggest issue
for me in this challenge
is I have never had
a canister fail on me
so I don't know what to do
if it does.
I have done three canisters.
[laughs]
Ron's taking his billet
over to the drill press.
[Ben] Yeah, he might put
a vent hole in his canister.
If you want to be exacting,
do it the same way every time
and you'll get the same results.
She's going for drilling a hole
as well.
-[Doug] Same thing.
-[Wil] Oh man.
This is the way
the family does it.
-[Doug] Yep.
-[Ron] Looking good.
Hot metal.
-Ron comes off the press...
-Hot metal coming back.
...and like clockwork, Jessica's
there to take his place.
Okay, Jessica's
not really pressing
as much as she oughta be.
I don't have enough weight
behind me
to actually make the bar go down
as much as I want it to go down.
I have to kind of rock myself,
put my weight forward
and move back,
have to go forward again.
[Wil] I noticed Ron,
while she was doing that.
Of course. You're watching over
your little apprentice.
Your own child.
And either you're beaming
or you're concerned.
[Ron] I have a really good
forge weld.
I know that I'm gonna do
an integrated bolster,
and so I'm setting that up.
The reason I'm putting in
the bolster
is because I've got
such a long blade,
I want more weight to be
right back by the index finger.
Jesse's profile's
coming along great.
I wanna make sure I have holes
in my tang by end of the round,
and drilling through hard steel
is never a good option.
So I've decided to go ahead
and drift those holes in.
Couple of heats,
had all three of my holes done.
[Wil] Jessica's really gonna
have to ramp it up here
because she still just has
a rectangular billet.
It's taking me slightly longer
to forge out my billet
than I had hoped.
I'm behind everybody
on the floor.
Hopefully, if I pace myself
right, I should be okay.
[dramatic music playing]
[Jesse] I've got a small warp.
There's nothing I can't
take off with a grinder.
[Wil] Jesse really doing
a bang-up job.
[metallic whirring]
[Ron] I'm behind schedule,
and so I start to second-guess
a little bit
the decision on putting
a bolster in there.
There are risks
with doing this.
This was not something
the judges asked for.
I don't know if they're
going to appreciate it.
[Wil] I like what Ron's doing,
putting in an integral bolster.
Super sexy pants.
-How you doin'?
-Hangin' in there.
-Time good?
-I think so.
[Ron] It's different in this
environment with my daughter
because I'm not just thinking
about my own thing in my head,
I'm also thinking about hers.
I'm not interfering,
not doing anything,
but it's still in the back
of my head,
"I wonder how she's doing."
[dramatic rock music playing]
[Wil] Look at Jessica
swing this hammer
like she wants the money.
Finally Jessica's
making a blade.
[Jessica] My plan now is to be
done forging in five minutes
and then have my holes
drilled for my tang,
and then get it to grind,
to quench, and get it edged.
There's a lot
of little steps between.
A lot could go wrong,
but a lot could also go right.
-Looks awesome, Jessie.
-Thanks!
-Yeah, Dad. Woo!
-[David] Yes!
-All right.
-Nice.
[Ben] At this point,
both fathers have quenched
and neither child has quenched.
[dramatic music playing]
[Wil] Whoa!
You didn't need that ponytail,
did ya, kid?!
Jessica's blade seems to be
very, very thick
and she has yet to grind down
to a high-carbon steel edge.
Yeah, and then get it clean
enough so you can edge it.
-Yep.
-[Doug] What I love
is the family dynamics here.
Because you're not
doing it alone.
There's a spiritual support
you're going through.
I know my blade is too thick
so I try to hog some steel off
real quick.
Three, two, one!
Bladesmiths, pull your blades
out of the acid.
This first round of competition
is over!
[judges applaud]
Time's finally up. I don't know
whether to pass out or lay down.
Bladesmiths, welcome
to the strength test.
To test the strength
and durability of your edge,
as well as the overall
construction of your blades,
I will be bashing them
mercilessly into these poles.
Ron, you're first. Ready?
Absolutely. Have at it.
[dramatic rock music playing]
[music fades]
[tense music playing]
Well, Ron, you've got
a pretty obtuse edge
which is good
at avoiding damage,
not the best for fine cutting.
There's one tiny place here
that has glinting on it.
But other than that,
the edge is in good shape.
One thing I don't like
about this knife
is right here.
It is round and small.
And there was a couple times
when I was hitting
where the blade would just
twist in my hand.
But it was comfortable.
It's just difficult to control
because of the size of it.
Yes, sir.
Jessica, you see
what we're up to.
-You ready?
-Yes, sir.
[dramatic music slowly builds]
[dramatic electronic music
playing]
-Good job.
-Thank you.
[Ben] Well, Jessica...
there's a glint
that happened right there.
The rest of your edge
held up really well.
But there are sharp corners
here on the handle
that were biting into my pinky.
But much less weight
than it had before.
-So, well done.
-Thank you.
Jesse, you're up.
How are you thinking?
Um... little nervous,
but have fun.
[dramatic rock music playing]
[music fades]
Well, Jesse, I like
the profile you got here.
It's got a pretty obtuse edge
for everyday use,
but it makes a good chopper.
So it held up well in this test.
Although it's a relatively
simple-looking handle,
it's a comfortable handle.
So, in all,
your edge held up well,
it's a good-feeling
and good-working knife.
-Well done.
-Thank you.
[dramatic music playing]
All right, gang, it's time
for the sharpness test.
The apple slice.
I'm looking for where the apple
is cut all the way through.
Not cut partially through
and broken the rest of the way.
-Ron, you're first. Ready?
-Absolutely.
[dramatic music playing]
[tense music playing]
[David] Okay, Ron. So...
pretty obtuse edge.
And you can see that half
that apple is cut smoothly,
and then it cracks.
It's a fat edge.
But will it cut?
Yes, it will cut.
Gotcha.
All right, Jessica,
you're next. Ready?
-Yes, sir.
-Okay.
[dramatic music playing]
[tense music playing]
So, Jessica, you can see
on this blade
that one side is almost flat
and the other side
kinda curves down to it.
So I start going through
the apples, just whoosh.
Like a wing.
Rode right up out of 'em.
The biggest thing is,
the square edges on this handle,
I feel all these corners.
But you did a good job
getting a lot of weight out
of the blade of this knife,
and it will cut.
You got that going for you.
All right, Jesse. You're up.
-Ready?
-I think so.
[dramatic music playing]
-Yeah, buddy.
-Thank you. Thank you.
[dramatic rock music playing]
[David] So Jesse,
what I'm looking at here is
actually some pretty clean cuts
on these apples.
Thank you.
That's a good shape.
Cut apples nicely. Good job.
Thank you.
[Wil] All right, Bladesmiths,
the judges' deliberation
is complete.
They've made
their final decision.
It's time for one of you smiths
to leave the Forge.
The Bladesmith
leaving the Forge is...
[dramatic music playing]
...Jessica.
Your blade did not make the cut.
Doug Marcaida's
gonna tell you why.
Jessica, your edge
wasn't as sharp
as that of your competitors,
and your handle
had some hot spots
that made it uncomfortable to
swing during the strength test.
For that reason,
we're sending you home.
Right.
Jessica, you did
a fantastic job,
but at this time, I have to
ask you to surrender your blade
and leave the Forge.
[Jessica]
Obviously I'm disappointed
but at the same time,
I am thrilled for my dad.
I get to go back home and be
my dad's biggest cheerleader.
-Take it for the Hardmans.
-[Wil] Aw.
This competition came down
to the details.
When I get home, I'm gonna
give my family a big hug
and go hang out with my dogs.